10 years ago we used to say oh well if  you don't like Google build your own  Google you know that's the free market  at work I'm not sure how free that  market is by the way but regardless if  if my rights are being taken away by the  U.S federal government that bugs me if  my rights are being taken away by Google  and I don't know Facebook and all these  corporations that are frankly less  accountable to me even than the  government is and that's damning with  faint praise well I don't like that  either and and I I refuse to sit idly by  in the name of some quote-unquote  principled conservatism which I think is  neither conservative nor particularly  principled and allow these corporations  to take away our freedom you know the  government is not the only threat to our  freedom